as our Cable competitors are devoting
hours of coverage today to the
president's tweet about stormy Daniels
voters I think are just tuning them out
why because the voters are smarter than
the media think they are as usual
Americans outside the leftist activist
bubble are focused on issues that
actually affect their daily lives
pocketbook issues like the stock market
jump 500 points today tech stocks way up
that's good for your 401k and the Labor
Department reported that there are 7
million job openings currently in the
United States and our industrial output
is surging all fantastic news but
Americans also see some trouble on the
horizon as well lawlessness at the
border that no advanced society should
tolerate now we have another mass of
people as many as 4,000 I'm told another
so-called migrant caravan making its way
from Honduras to the United States and
President Trump has had just about
enough we have the dumbest immigration
laws in the world the world laughs at us
but we're getting have changed we need
some more Republicans we need to vote
I'll say and for many years voters have
been telling politicians enforce the
border and close immigration loopholes
in fact even on the issue of legal
immigration a lot of people don't know
this the country is not clamoring for
big increases check this out
only 28 percent of Americans want
immigration levels increased 29 percent
of Americans want them decreased adult
plurality as you see want them just to
remain the same of course most
politicians continue to just ignore the
wishes of the people so what they do is
they continue to expand things like
distant relative chain migration they
refuse to allocate money for the
building of the entire wall at the
southern border and they refuse to pass
legislation to allow for immediate
border turn backs of anyone crossing the
border illegally and of course Democrats
are just against all tightening
of the current ridiculous rules for
asylum Donald Trump won the presidency
in large part because he wouldn't accept
the status quo on immigration and as
usual he was five steps ahead of most
every Republican congressman on the
issue in July Gallup found that
Americans identified immigration as the
top issue for them going into the
midterms last month it was the second
most important issue tied with just
general economic problems Democrats
thought I think that a focus on the
difficult issue of child separation a
practice that the administration has now
ended that that would turnout voters and
get Democrats or Latino voters really
excited to get out there but I don't
think it's working for him
and remember back in 2016 the Latino
voter turnout rate didn't increase
despite Trump's push for the wall and a
lot of stronger immigration enforcement
and of course Hispanic Americans are
themselves disproportionately affected
by the impact of illegal immigration in
their neighborhoods in their communities
and ditto for black Americans the good
news is that as the second Caravan drama
unfolds it turns out that some
established establishment Republicans
are waking up to the wisdom of Trump
it makes the immigration debate more on
Trump's terms you know there is no right
to come to America you know we can't
have rules about who comes and where's
Mexico Mexico needs to help us ghost us
last time I checked you just can't walk
from Guatemala to here without going to
Mexico
oh yeah and today the president warned
the president of Honduras if the large
caravan of people heading to the US has
not stopped and brought back to Honduras
he's going to cut off foreign aid
vice-president pants had separately
warned the presidents of Honduras
Guatemala and El Salvador to tell their
people do not make the dangerous trek to
America saying the US will not tolerate
this blatant disregard for our border
and sovereignty by the way Honduras is
on track to receive sixty five point
seven million dollars in foreign aid
from the US in the upcoming
year 2019 but back to the midterms as
frustrated as so many of us are with the
Republicans and what they failed to do
at the border well the cause may be
totally lost if the open borders
Democrats take the house well the
president is focused on important things
like abolishing the illegal immigrant
gang ms-13 Democrats want to abolish ice
we need to rebuild a system from top to
bottom starting by replacing ice with
something we can replace it and we can
replace it with a humane agency that is
directed towards faith passage what is
amenable a criminalization safe passage
everybody come on in and Warren and
Acacio Cortez are not alone of course
there are a lot more like them that
believe the same thing again the choice
could not be clearer for the midterm
voters there's so much on the line for
America will Trump get the funding for
his wall will the mass migration from
other poor countries in Central America
be stopped at all ever will travesty
such as birthright citizenship finally
be ended will we mandate a verified to
penalize businesses who game the system
to keep American wages low of this my
friends you can be sure your views on
immigration will have zero impact and
zero influence on a House dominated by
Democrats who want to replace you the
American voters with newly amnestied
citizens and an ever increasing number
of chained migrants if Republicans
choose to unite however behind the
president's immigration policy the way
they just did in the Cavanaugh fight
this will Stoke voter enthusiasm even
further ahead of the all too important
midterm election and that's the angle